we are devoting the rest of the
broadcast to our earth matters coverage
as carbon dioxide levels continue to
rise every year big cities are looking
for ways to go green this month London
introduced the world's first ultra low
emission zone to fight the city's toxic
levels of air pollution it is one of the
most radical anti-pollution policies on
the planet Mark Phillips takes us for a
ride in London to show us how the
polluter pays you don't have to go
somewhere exotic to run into the effects
of climate change these days the drive
around central London will do it and
because of environmental concerns that
drive has gotten a lot more expensive
for some lately approached central
London then you'll see these signs
announcing a charge just for bringing
your car into town could chain about 15
bucks and if you've got an older car
especially if it's a diesel the overhead
cameras will spot you and under the new
ultra low emission zone that'll be
another 16 and a half bucks
that's over $30 just to drive into town
why just ask the mayor if y'all gonna
drive from with a more pollution vehicle
you have to pay for that the point of
Mayors Sadiq Khan charges is to reduce
pollution by reducing the number of
vehicles which produce it so this is the
iconic graph of atmospheric co2
concentrations at the British Met Office
the country's weather forecasting
service they track the rise of carbon
dioxide the most prevalent greenhouse
gas much of the data coming from the
Mauna Loa Observatory in Hawaii which
has been measuring co2 since 1958
scientists like Richard Betts count the
gas in parts per million of the air
around us so he's almost at 300 in the
beginning way past 400 now so a 30%
increase in co2 over that half century
or more and why is that significant it's
America because it's causing the world
to warm up in just that period average
global temperatures have risen about one
degree Fahrenheit arise scientist
connect to more severe weather increased
flooding and droughts there's still
skeptics out there somehow either doubt
the source of the extra co2 in the
atmosphere and where it's coming from
even the skeptics those who are
disputing that it's a problem will
accept that the science is sound in that
the warming is caused by increased
greenhouse gases over the past few years
we've been going to some of the Earth's
extreme environments where the signs of
climate change tend to show up first
we found that carbon that's been frozen
in the Arctic permafrost is being
released as it thaws we found Antarctic
Islands where penguin colonies used to
thrive that are now almost empty because
the sea ice is gone we've seen the coral
bleaching due to warming
on Australia's Great Barrier Reef they
used to simply produce daily weather
forecasts in places like this now they
can also look further into the future so
we can't predict individual weather days
more than a few days ahead but we can
make predictions of the annual average
temperature in the seasonal temperature
and rainfall and we're predicting that a
warmer world changing rainfall patterns
and rising sea levels the trend is up
yeah and if London is any example the
way we move around and the way we live
our lives will change too and on today's
CBS this morning podcast Mark shares
what he has learned about climate change
while reporting around the world for his
Climate diaries series listen wherever
you get your podcasts so if you have to
pay more because your car is putting out
more pollution do you think you'll get
another car yes yeah I would - I would
think so too
another example everybody can do a
little something like the bus oh yeah or
take the bus